European Union Finance and economy
ministers hope to clinch by the end of
the year an agreement on a common
approach to new rules to preempt bank
crises following talks in brussels what
was really a unanimous unanimous
position it was that we must find an
agreement in the console before the end
of the year as it was decided by the
European Council but it is also the
feeling of the Member States of my
colleagues that it should be done that
and that it can be done the EU
presidency has tasked a working group to
take forward negotiations on the
proposals for the so-called single
resolution mechanism and single bank
resolution fund the aims to help a
struggling credit institution or
investment firm to recover from any
shock in an orderly manner preserving
its operations and minimizing the
possibility of taxpayer losses the
proposals are a key part of the e used
banking Union The ministers also sought
to reach a political agreement on rules
governing savings taxation a large
majority of nations supported the plan
which would oblige authorities to
exchange information so that interest
payments made in one nation to people
from another EU state are taxed under
the laws of their country of residence
the goal is to help fight tax evasion